Joining us now is the former
speaker of the U.S.
House of Representatives, Paul Ryan.
Good to see you, sir.
Thanks for being here. Appreciate it.
I want to get to Kevin McCarthy
in a moment.
But first, with all this news
about classified documents,
whether President Biden
or President Trump,
I want to just ask you,
as somebody
who when you were speaker of the House,
had access
to classified documents,
if you could like
give us some sort of insight into
how easy or not
or difficult
it might be to actually accidentally or.
No, I never took them home.
I left them in my safe in the office.
Is that right?
And they went from my safe
in the office down to the skiff
and then back to the safe in the office.
I never I never took them on my body.
They were in locked briefcases,
so I never even took them
out of the office.
But I guess it would be different
if you're president.
Maybe I'm trying to figure it out.
Whether you're trying to buy it.
It's the system
you put in place in your office, I guess.
And you had a rigid system,
a rigid system
which they want
from the intelligence community
to a safe in my office,
that one cleared
staffer of mine had access to,
we would take them from the safe
down to the skiff,
which is underground in the Capitol.
I would read them
there, discuss them
there at my briefings.
There we go back to the office,
and they'd go in that safe in either
the SCIF safe
or in the safe in my office,
and they would not go nowhere else.
Sounds like a pretty good process.
That's the way we do things.
Yeah.
Okay, so let's talk about the House race,
because this hasn't happened.
We saw something
last week
that hasn't happened in 100 years.
And longer.
If you want to go
to the number of ballots,
a serious battle
on the floor of the House
to be speaker of the House
and some very serious
personal criticisms
of the man who ultimately
won the election.
Kevin McCarthy,
including about whether or not
he's trustworthy
and the like
as a friend of his,
as somebody who was speaker when
he was House majority leader,
what was going through your mind
when you watched it all play out?
I thought he was going to gut it out.
I didn't think he'd take 15 votes.
So I suppose between like vote
four and 14,
I wasn't so sure, but I still thought
there was no alternative.
So because there was
really no alternative.
That's kind of the dynamic was different.
When I was there, because I was seen
as the alternative
and I was not looking for the job.
I sort of got drafted into it,
but there was no dynamic like that
at play here.
And Kevin had done so much more.
First of all, remember,
I came midterm, so Boehner,
it was a motion to vacate
was being placed upon Boehner.
So I came midterm
Kevin had just worked his tail off
to campaign and fundraise
to build this majority
over two cycles, and he did that.
So it's a different dynamic
than what occurred in 2015 with me,
which was Kevin
was the leader of the conference
as a minority leader for two cycles
built that majority
and then there really wasn't
another alternative for people to go to.
So I really thought that
he would get through it
even with this type of tough margin.
I just didn't
think it take 15 votes
in all those concessions that it took
but it did.
There's this moment
well let's just show it right now
where obviously we're Armed Services
Committee Chairman Mike Ryan.
You even have to show me the picture.
I see.
There he is lunging at Congressman
Matt Gates after Gates
did not vote I
thus stopping McCarthy
from winning on the 14th ballot.
Does this bode ill
for your party's ability
to unite and actually govern?
Look, no.
I mean, these guys are get
that's where drugs and behind aren't
very good friends of mine.
Richards, a good friend of Mike's.
Mike just got hot under the collar.
He just got you know,
they were pretty exasperated
by that time.
And my understanding is Matt
Gates was going to vote
for him on that 14 vote
and then changed his mind in the vote
without telling anybody
That makes people pretty upset.
So look hot heads happen.
Things like that occur
by the way
that's what the floor is like
when you ever have any contentious vote
I just know
C-SPAN usually doesn't cover that
because the cameras
but it's always like that
so should we have.
When you have difficult votes
Gates wants the cameras.
And I have to say
I know I'm not I'm
not a fan of their performance
art that has overtaken
our politics in the entertainment wings
of both of our parties.
This would just feed into that.
So, no, I'm actually not a fan of that.
But that is what the floor is
like when you have tough,
contentious votes.
I've seen that movie
a million times over.
You just haven't seen it on C-SPAN.
And no,
I don't want to see the cameras do that
because people are going to play
to the cameras
on the floor of Congress,
like they play to the cameras
everywhere else
they do in politics these days.
Well, the counterargument would be
you also see the humanity
that Republicans sitting together
will have too much entertainment
in politics these days.
So I frankly like to see that toned down.
I don't want to
add more gas to that fire.
Such a buzz kill.
McCarthy made so many concessions
to this wing.
The chip Roy,
Matt Gates,
whoever, whatever Harry
want to call it, these
insurgents, these rebels,
too.
And he made these concessions
to get their votes.
And without question,
the concessions
weakened the speakership and empowered
individual members.
The motion to vacate
you mentioned
in which
they got rid of John
Boehner is now back to one vote
as it was before.
But there are other
other things in terms of
who was on the Rules Committee
opening up the process.
Anybody can offer a bill.
Anybody can offer amendment.
I like some of those, by the way.
Some of those are pretty good.
Well, the 72 hour one is a great one.
The idea that you need 72 hours
to read a bill before you can vote
with the appropriations ones.
I like that.
So frankly,
I think
I don't want to cut you off
on your question.
But let me say this.
I think I had too much power as speaker.
Oh, really?
I really do.
Yeah, absolutely.
Look,
the thing that bothered me
the most were these omnibus,
you know, a bill up that thick
that for people
ultimately decide on
15 spending bills crunched together 12
crunched together
and and it's thousands of pages.
It would be myself,
Nancy, Chuck and Mitch
I'm sorry
that House speaker
you know, every leader
you know what I'm talking about.
They were your friends, basically.
Well, some of them are ish.
Yeah. Yes.
We all get along.
We all respect one another.
The problem is no.
Four people should be doing all of that,
making those decisions.
And, you know,
frankly,
I was making decisions on composition
of spending bills.
You know, I think I'm
a smart, principled person.
But the guy and the man,
the woman who's in the committee in
the subcommittee is spending
two years reading inspector
general reports, GAO reports on those.
They should be making those decisions,
not kicked up to elected leadership.
Are there any new rules
or rule changes that concern you
in terms of the free
for all, in terms
of whether or not what we saw last week
is going to be kind of like the new norm?
I think the vacated has become
weaponized now.
It's become normalized as an activity.
I never worry about this myself, frankly,
but that was just kind of my own dynamic,
I suppose.
But I think members now
see this as sort of a tool
they can take for a ride.
I think that's bad for the institution.
The last thing John Boehner, literally
the last words
John Boehner said to me
as he walked out the door
of his Smoke-Filled office
that I took over
was don't forget
your number one job
is to preserve this institution,
defend the institution
and if you're a committee chair,
which is what I was, I was
chair of Ways and Means of Time.
I never really thought about that.
Most members
don't think about the institution. Right.
You're thinking about your policy agenda
or whatever it is
you want to get done in Congress.
That's not normally
what you're thinking of.
So I became a big institutionalist,
but it took me a little while once
I became speaker
because I realized
just how important
for our freedom
in our liberty, in our democracy.
This is
talk about your book, American Renewal
The Conservative Plan
to Strengthen the Social Contract
and Save the Country's Finances.
We are
currently economists
say whether we're in a recession or not,
they're definitely headed into something
called a slow session.
This morning, new inflation numbers show
the surging price is fading slightly.
Inflation is still a threat.
What if you were advising
Kevin McCarthy
in the House Republicans right now
What would you tell them to do
about the U.S. economy?
They know what I think.
I'm still friends with these guys.
I think look, what
what I say in this book
is, first, of all,
the best case
for America
is a really long lost generation,
a stagflation
that is going to last more
than just like a Japanese lost decade.
If we don't get our act together,
that's the best case scenario.
We're likely
to have more of a debt crisis,
which CBO talks about in projects,
which is really ugly.
That means the social contract
is unaffordable.
That means
if you think we're polarized today,
wait till we have a debt crisis.
So what we're putting in this book
are all the solutions
we think are necessary
to make sure
that we can make good
on our social contract,
which I would argue
center left and center right.
We agree on.
We want health and retirement security.
We want a safety net.
We believe
in Medicare and Social Security,
Medicaid.
So let's make these things solvent.
Let's make them work better.
Let's make them guaranteed
for the current retirees
and make them solvent
for the next generation
so that they're there when we retire.
That takes persuasion politics.
So I know that when you were speaker
and Donald Trump was president,
you guys would talk about this
and he did not understand
why you would ever want to do it,
because it's bad policy. That's right.
You just didn't think was ever popular.
And he has
and I'm not blaming this on him,
but he has certainly empowered
the kind of populism
you're talking about,
smash mouth clicks
with cable hits on Fox, etc.,
where you're a board member.
By the way, he has popularized that.
He is empowered that we saw it last week.
So how can this be achieved
even within the Republican Party
before you even get to the Democrats?
A couple of things?
He's fading fast. He's a proven loser.
He cost us the House at 18.
He cost us the White House in 2008,
cost us the Senate again and again.
And I think we all know that.
And I think we're moving past Trump.
I really think that's the case.
I, I can't imagine him
getting the nomination, frankly.
And I don't mean this
because I don't want it.
I don't want to get the nomination.
I just don't think he will
as an analytical point
that the thing that
I that I take solace
in with all the machinations
you saw last week,
most of that wasn't personal.
Most of that was around
fiscal responsibility.
Most of that was about a concern
about spending, inflation and debt.
That's great.
I think you need to persuade the country
as to the solutions and the problem.
And I don't think
brinksmanship solves those things.
But what's behind that is a good thing,
which is Republicans
finally requiring their moorings
on the party of fiscal
responsibility and limited government.
That to me is the good thing that I see
in all of this weird stuff.
That's the good thing.
So the question is, can
we put very positive in reform
in substance?
Yeah, well, I'm a Republican.
I am not a member of the organized party.
I'm a Republican.
This very nice little Will Rogers.
So the point I'm trying to make is
those juices are flowing
and that is churning.
And I think we're
we're hopefully coming back
full circle to being
maybe a populist party.
That's great and fun.
I want to be popular,
but principled and with policy
is that solve problem with governance?
Yeah.
Fiscal conservatism is is
was a theme that you saw behind
all of those taxes here.
What's a good thing?
When Congressman Chip Roy
was on
State of the Union on Sunday,
he said we know this
debt crisis is coming with a debt ceiling
like hearing that.
Let's get let's get working on it now.
Right. As opposed to July. Right.
I don't think you'll fix it
with a debt crisis,
but I think you need to go
persuade the country and offer solutions.
And having gavels and chairmanships.
I had two of them.
That's what you do.
You build the case in Ways and Means
in financial services
and Budget Committee.
You show the public what
what's what's going on
and why our solutions are better and why,
frankly,
if you just
whistle past the graveyard,
ignore these problems,
you're hurting Americans,
you're hurting the social
your kids are my kids.
Your social contract. Yes.
Not just our kids, but seniors. Sure.
So that's what I meant.
Like when you and I are seniors,
that's that's
that's what I was referring to.
Last quick question.
Congressman George
Santos, he's lied about
apparently everything on his resumé.
At least
six House Republicans
have said he should resign,
including five New York Republicans.
Do you agree?
Sure. Yeah, sure, I agree.
My guess is they'll probably let
the Ethics Committee run its course.
It's a fraudulent candidacy.
This isn't a embellished candidacy
to fraudulent candidacy.
He hopes to his voters.
So, of course, he should step down.
He doesn't
strike me as an honorable person, though.
I don't know the guy.
So my guess is
it will probably go through
the ethics course.
I can't imagine the guy's going to stay
very long.
All right.
Former House Speaker Paul Ryan,
good to see you, sir.
Thanks for being here. Good to see Jake.